hey guys today I'm going to talk about
the importance of Holland read mirror
father who is decided start the only man
that survived the fight against Archer
Dean and at the same time save Ned from
a certain death how Anne Reid demanded
of the first to charge against the sword
of the morning whereupon he was slashed
across the chest by Dane and almost died
but also a man who say it meant from a
certain death statement stark who gave
his best but couldn't stand a chance
against her archer Dane superior
fighting skills and got himself disarmed
this same man the Lord of greywater
watch the father of Meera and Jojen Reed
loyal vassal of House Stark Colin Reed
has played very important role in Starks
life with saving man from a certain
death is playing a very important role
because if not for his children bran
wouldn't have probably even become a
three-eyed raven in addition he would
have probably been dead and will
doubtlessly play a huge role in the
upcoming seasons considering that he is
the only living person that knows the
truth
beside rant about Jon's true identity
house read and how stark have been
allies for a long time Howland was one
of the few people that Ned brought with
him south of the tower of joy beside Ned
Lord Reed was the only man that survived
five against one of the best swordsmen
that the Seven Kingdoms have ever had
meaning that he knows the secret a
secret which only two people in the
entire world no brain only knows about
his lineage due to his ability of having
a visions of the past but how and Reed
was actually there
Hollan leighton-jones birth now that Jon
has been declared as the king in the
north
while at the same time brand knows the
truth about John's identity bran might
reveal the truth to Jon about his
parents even though I don't think bran
will reveal it to Jon on their first
meeting in my opinion Brandon firstly
tried to find a proof from either the
books or even from Howland Reed at the
first place since Brian knows that
Howard was there beside bad and knows
pretty much every single detail that
happened in the Tower of joy since
branch saw him in his visions
even if bran wouldn't decide to find a
proof from either Howland Reed or from
the books even if he would decide to
reveal the truth to Jon without any hard
proof
in that case the proofs are still of the
greatest need
since Johnny D is inner voice from be
able to roll over the kingdom while his
own people don't know the truth John
would want to reveal his true identity
even if that would lead him losing his
title as the king which I truly doubt
but to reveal the truth he needs some
kind of proof and that might be the
moment in which Holland is going to
appear not only the time expecting from
showrunners to bring Holland trained in
the show but I'm also expecting for
showrunners to bring a few explanations
so along with Holland for an example
what was Howland doing this whole time
while his son died for Ned's son and
while his daughters to be on the wall
protecting brain house Reed has a long
history with the Starks they were always
loyal to their stone house by Lord
Howland Reed also fought in Robert's
rebellion alongside Eddard Stark beside
being alongside Eddard in rebellion and
saving that same man's life Holland was
also there alongside Ned when his best
friend discovered that his sister Lyanna
gave a birth to her son to a son that
night represented as his own which
brought dishonor to him but at the same
time brought him the most honorable
thing that he had done throughout his
life kept the promise that he gave to
his dying sister beside Ned who gave a
promise to his sister and kept it with
him throughout his own life at the same
time Howland Reed demanded first met his
Lords starts at the great tourney at
Harrenhal when he was a young man a
young man that was beaten up and cursed
by Terry Squires until the Anna came to
his defense whereupon he shared a table
with the Starks from a feast at night
where he eventually met up with Lee
Anna's three brothers he met up with
Eddard Brandon and Benjen stark the same
man whose friendship and loyalty are
highly marbled Holland reed was
alongside ned when the son of the heir
to the throne was born and just like mad
captain keeps that secret quiet for all
these years and will keep through his
whole life for his best friend Ned and
for Liana for the brave girl that
defended his honor
at the great tourney at Harrenhal
unquestionably
I was willing to take the secret which
is great but the bran or John would come
to him and ask from him to reveal the
truth Holland would no longer have to
keep the secret
in which I expected happen throughout
the upcoming seasons how much Howland
Reed respects and love Starks says the
fact that he kept this huge secret for
all these years was one factors itself
how good friends how in the network
how much Hollins cared about his best
friend attacked from the third season
which Jojen told the brand while
traveling in the gift Georgian told the
brand that he told his father about his
visions of what had happened to Ned
Stark it was the first time he saw his
father crying I don't know if it's just
me but I don't see how and Reed not
appearing in season 7 I can't imagine
that the only purpose of house reading
Game of Thrones series would be
Holland's children Meera and Jojen
escorting brand to the three-eyed Raven
I'm not saying that their roles were
useless not to mention that it was one
of the most important tasks that any
character could get but I can't imagine
how three disappearing after mere
escorts branch of interval Holland has
managed to stay out of a big amount of
the major Wars that help place the
Westeros which in my opinion is because
of Jojen visions and Howlin himself both
of them probably knew that the most
important war is yet to come
that the real wars coming but that war
is here now the winter is not coming
anymore
the winter is here it's time for Howland
to stop hiding and come out of his swamp
with his management to come out and to
swear fealty to the new king in the
north
while I'm expecting for show runners to
bring Holland in the show along with a
few explanations I also have a
prediction which might come true in the
last eight season I have a prediction
that major battle between the living and
the dead will take place in the bog fill
lands of the neck due to it being a
strategic choke point which is ruled
over by house read the neck is a swamp
and marsh filled region of Westeros
located by the water so the bite Inlet
of the Shivering sea and blade water bay
and inlet of the sunset sea you're
relatively close to one another the neck
is the southernmost part of the north on
the border with the river lands and
divides the north from the rest of the
Seven Kingdoms
at this point the swamps are overgrown
and flooded to the east and wealth at
large armies can only pass north or
south by following the path of the
kingsroad among all of these advantages
of the neck being the best place for the
living side-to-side defense on the
result Isles which could be their
biggest Vantage if they would know how
to use it perfectly it's a fact that the
neck presents a formidable tactical
obstacle to anyone planning to invade it
and most of the most important thing
holding off the Andals during their
invasion of Westeros 6,000 years ago
while it was the factor in stopping the
armies which contained only man it was
not effective against dragons which led
King tore and Stark the last king in the
north
to his decision to bend the knee to egg
on the Conqueror it's also important to
highlight the fact that the neck is
considered the key to any assault on the
north let me read you a few quotes that
will hopefully demonstrate you how the
neck could be very important for Jon
Snow could help and could be of
tremendous importance for the link side
let's start with Eddard Starks
conversation with Catelyn Stark imagenet
told her that 200 the turned archers can
hold the neck against Normie
let's also mention that beta land grazer
is said the neck is the key to the
kingdom and the last quote that I'm
going to mention is mirror reads few
sentences our land protects its own an
outsider will find in the neck and
endless morris of suckholes quicksands
and green red that looks solid to the
moai but turns in water the instant you
thread it hopefully these few quotes
demonstrate you the huge potential that
an egg possess and could be big if not
the biggest advantage of the link side
of course after Dana's dragons and
wildfire after I brought you the
importance of Howland Reed and region
that Howland rules over now I'm going to
discuss from a fattie read that is
folding around a theory in which lianna
gave a birth to twins to Jon Snow and
Meera Reed a theory in which Howland is
not only keeping a secret but also
raised the daughter of Leanna Game of
Thrones fans kind of started approving
this theory at the moment in which Ellie
Kendrick
the actors displays Meera get an
interview with a huffington post and
reply to a question that included this
theory with I don't know they still
really never seen where Jojen and Meera
have come from we know a little tiny
about her father we don't know anything
about her mother really so yeah
to find out who her parents are and what
situation is her response is more than
confusing since she first said that they
know a little bit about her father while
we don't know anything about her mother
only to say at the end that she's
excited to find out who her parents are
I mean didn't she just say and kind of
confirmed that how it is not her father
well maybe John Snow and Mina Reid are
the same age and are looking very
similar or sharing certain physical
traits and it'll make sense if Leanna
really gave birth to me right John that
net took John with him and represented
him as his bastard son while Holland
Oakley and his daughter and represented
her as his daughter separated them at
the bird to keep them safe the anonymity
of the neck and the loyalty along with
friendship of Hans Reid would make gray
would watch a safe place for Ned's needs
to grow up but the theory might be
plausible for the most of fans I'm not
the one that finds this theory is the
true one I don't find it as it should
because the biggest proof of this theory
apparently is in fact that in the Tower
of joy over two hand maidens and
apparently while one handmaiden was
gaining John to mad
the other one was cleaning the second
child since they are twins and were born
at the same time the only truth from
this statement is that in the Tower of
joy birth to hand maidens while the part
in which one of them was leaning the
baby is simply not true since they could
see both of them in the moment of Ned's
entrance into the room of which one was
holding a baby while the other one was
just standing beside her in conclusion
I'm expecting from showrunners to bring
Colin rain in the show along with a few
explanations while I hope that living
sides will realize the next sole
advantages as Ned did let me know your
opinion on all of this in the comment
section down below I'm curious what your
thoughts are about Howland Reed so yeah
let me know hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next one peace
[Music]
you